Good morning team, welcome to the EMEA week one kickoff. We have 30 minutes. Three things on the agenda: where we stand against the quarter, our top deals with a focus on Corso del Centro and the new Istanbul inbound, and weekly commitments. Eleanor, please open with the dashboard. Chiara, you are up right after on Corso. Niklas, please be ready with Nordic Apparel, and Yusuf, we will close with Istanbul. Let's get into it.
Thanks Lucas. On the dashboard, EMEA is tracking at 103 percent of plan year to date, leading the three regions. The strength is concentrated in Southern Europe, specifically Italy and Spain. Northern Europe is at plan, and the UK mid-market is the one soft spot, with two accounts that have pushed into next quarter. The top deals this quarter are Corso del Centro in Milan, Nordic Apparel across Sweden and Norway, and a brand-new Istanbul Tech retailer inbound that Yusuf will speak to.
If you look at the risk panel, the only items we are tracking are the two UK mid-market slips and a long sales cycle in Munich that we have already de-risked into next quarter. The risk-adjusted forecast remains at 102 to 105 percent of plan depending on Corso landing this quarter or next.
Great, thanks Eleanor. Two things. First, what is the upside if we land Corso this quarter versus next? Second, on the UK mid-market, is there anything Niklas or I can help unblock?
On Corso, landing this quarter pulls us to 108 percent. Slipping to next quarter still leaves us comfortably above plan but reduces our regional outperformance story for the CVP review. On the UK mid-market, both accounts are stuck on a procurement-process change at the customer side, not on us, so I do not think there is much we can do other than stay close. Happy to debrief offline.
Understood. Let's talk Corso. Chiara, what changed this week and what is the path to close?
Thanks Lucas. Big news on Corso. Their CIO reached out personally yesterday afternoon and asked us to host a partner conversation this Friday in Milan. The agenda they proposed has three items: commercial terms, integration prerequisites, and a four-week pilot proposal. This is the strongest signal we have had from them to date. The CIO also asked who our exec sponsor would be — that is a great signal but also a flag we need to think about.
Excellent signal. On exec sponsor, I will take that ask up the chain — I think we surface it to Mat at the cross-regional sync next week so he can decide whether he or the CVP plays that role. For Friday, what do you need from Yusuf and the team?
I need Yusuf on the call to handle the technical sections, specifically the integration prerequisites. I also need help drafting the commercial response by Wednesday so we have it pressure-tested at Thursday's triage. Eleanor, I might lean on you for the financial modeling on the pilot proposal.
Beautiful. Let's quickly do Nordic Apparel and Istanbul. Niklas, status please.
Nordic Apparel is in great shape. Both key accounts went to legal this morning, contracts on a fast-track template, and I expect signature within two weeks. The customer has confirmed they are willing to be a reference for Corso, which Eleanor flagged as helpful. No blockers from my side.
Excellent — please coordinate the reference call timing with Chiara. Yusuf, over to you on Istanbul.
New inbound this week from a mid-size Turkish retailer. They reached out via the website asking for a technical review. Two things stand out. One, they have very specific compliance asks around Turkish data residency that we should validate against the product roadmap before committing. Two, they specifically asked for the conversation to be in Turkish. I would like to bring this to Thursday triage with a one-page risk note so the team can align on how we want to position next steps. I will host a customer-facing technical review next Friday if triage gives the green light.
Great. Let's recap so the Facilitator captures cleanly. Action one: Chiara owns Corso Friday review with Yusuf on technical and Eleanor on pilot financials. Action two: I take the Corso exec-sponsor question to Mat at the cross-regional sync. Action three: Niklas closes Nordic and coordinates the reference call with Chiara. Action four: Yusuf publishes the Istanbul risk note before Thursday triage and stands by to host the customer review next Friday. Anything I missed?
Nothing additional from me. Thanks Lucas.
All clear. Talk Thursday.
Perfect. See everyone Thursday for triage. Have a great week.